we've got some breaking news for you
this is coming out of Istanbul we're
hearing in its local media they're
saying at least 11 people have been
injured in an explosion in on istikal
Avenue now if you know anything about
this Avenue it's a sort of lined of
cafes bars restaurants we're hearing so
it would have been busy we're hearing it
happened
from the governor of Istanbul at around
4 20
um he's saying it happened at 4 20 an
explosion occurred the police the health
and fire teams were sent to the scene
um there are casualties and injuries and
of course we'll share developments of
this story with you as we get it but as
we're hearing
uh into Sky News uh at least 11 people
have been injured in
an explosion in Istanbul and just to
reinforce that message this is on
Twitter the governor
of Istanbul tweeting that it happened at
around a 4 20 and there are casualties
and injuries and again this is a quite a
lively place
um istikal Street as I said bars
restaurants nightclubs so it would have
been quite a busy time around 4 20 this
afternoon we'll bring you more details
as we get it